here we are in the queues baby sin city
yeah
so much to do i'm overwhelmed you know
should i go to the mall should i get
drunk should i get an opioid addiction
who knows
i can't decide
yeah i spent most of the day in the mall
how are you doing sir that guy's just
going for a rap career it's not working
out but uh you know good to have you
back fatty
the ball is fun is that fun uh thing on
the ceiling for kids like a pedophile
trap you know
like a spider web for pedos you know
good times
whoa something about the mall
it really just brings out the sadness in
you huh
the third floor the higher up you go the
more tears you shed
it is chilly out there huh god damn you
guys are tough you're built tough a lot
of you ladies you really gotta scowl on
out there yeah
so a lot of these girls in this town
have really taken a few punches
what should i be doing in syracuse what
am i missing
oh titty bar
oh all right
are the titties different here than
other places
i've been to a lot of titty bars
bbqs
is that the strip club
butts boobs and
queers
all right bbqs okay good to know maybe
i'll get the steak and
watch some chicks with a c-section scar
sounds pretty hot
sounds like my childhood
do they have a gay bar in syracuse
wonderbar what was it
how come there's no lesbian bars like
scissors or some [ __ ] you know or
clips clitch would be a perfect name for
a lesbian bar because the men wouldn't
be able to find it
all right
yeah buddy what'd you say ma'am
stay tuned
what
so where are you guys headed after this
my place embassy suites room 308
that's how lonely i am i'll take a train
from these hooligans out here in the
middle of there
all right what kind of drugs
uh we'll do a little hyvermectin yeah
do we have a game we don't have any gay
guys either
that's a lady all right
non-binary oh look nobody knows what
that means let's be honest
that means you're not a man or a woman
in my closet
i mean
it's not really an insult she's got a
bunch of dicks in her closet
i only have one so if she has two
she's got more than me
but unless you take those out of the
closet those dicks are gay
i think you got me
all right
i saw she had blue hair and i tried to
avoid her but
she spoke up
what's that
clothing
all right do we have a black person
hey we got one all right
there we go
that should be the syracuse flag one jew
one black and a mall that's it
did i find the bike bike's gone i think
somebody had stolen but thanks for
bringing it up my girlfriend in college
had a miscarriage you want to talk about
that all right
what's that
the miscarriage that was pretty messy i
still have it i
kept it in some tupperware sometimes i
talk to it
oh no we're having fun we're having fun
but thank you sarah i'm sure you were
mad about the marilyn manson news